[Music]
you know you're the longest-running
headlining act in Las Vegas history when
you headlined at a theater named after
your team and at the Penn & Teller
theater at the Rio Hotel in Las Vegas
Nevada the comedy magic duo of Penn &
Teller worked their craft sixth season
of Penn & Teller foolís airing Monday at
8:00 Eastern 7:00 central on the CW good
to see you Penn Jillette how are you big
fan of yours for quite some time how did
you get started in this you know I
really didn't I mean I started out as a
juggler and Teller was the one that
pulled me into magic I I did not like
the idea of lying as an entertainment
and tell there was the one who told me
you could tell bigger truths and you
could be honest about your lying and
that was really a profound thing for my
gosh walk me through that mental jujitsu
no there's thing about magic as you're
making a deal with the audience that you
are going to trick them and you're going
to discuss how we ascertain what's true
and that's a pretty interesting
intellectual thing where you get to play
in an area that is very unpleasant
unless it's out in the open and it's
very kind of sweet and fun how did you
pan meet tell her
how did Utah but they're both UNAM
together I was a pilot he was would that
be good if that were true you're getting
great if that were true
I'm sure he's actually not I was just a
little bit too young for Nam tele didn't
go so we didn't nothing to do with
Vietnam was actually tell her went to
college with a guy who sold me a stereo
come on we should have stuck with the
noms do but that by the way I like that
one so okay is that a true story teller
teller went to Amherst College which is
in western Massachusetts right and I am
from a town near there okay Greenfield
and they someone who graduated memebers
College work in a stereo store in my
town and I went in with all the money
I'd saved up to finally buy a good
stereo and we got to talking
and we were talking about art and comedy
and ideas like that and he finally
introduced me to tell her who at that
time yes was a high school Latin teacher
in Trenton New Jersey
I forgot what level of Dante's hell
Latin teacher in New Jersey is but
close to the center it's Latin in New
Jersey that's that's amazing okay so was
when did you guys first perform then
when was it you know I got out of high
school on a plea bargain I didn't really
graduate and then I went to Ringling
Brothers Barnum Bailey greatest show on
earth Clown College and then because Bob
Dylan lied to me and I thought that the
hip thing to do was to hitchhike and hop
trains yes he didn't actually do this I
did yes and then after a couple of years
I convinced teller to actually quit his
tenured job as a Latin teacher and team
up with a 19 year old to do a magic show
and and that's what we did and that's
and that was 44 years 40 actually 44
years ago I think a week and a half ago
so 44 years we can I have pets how long
Penn & Teller's been at in pens all the
time and yes sure did oh when did okay
was it always settled that teller
wouldn't talk that predates me when I
first met teller he was already an
accomplished magician he was kind of a
child prodigy yes and he was already not
speaking so he brought me on to do the
talking at first I was a juggler and
then I learned a little bit of magic
over 40 I imagine you have picked up
something so he's never has he ever
talked on stage he always talks a little
on stage you know when we do fool
lessons stuff once in a while who throw
in a vo or once in a while to say
something and we do this thing you know
we try to trust the audience as much as
we can and assume that they are at least
as smart as we are which you've always
been accurate on but when the audience
comes out of the show and this is
unusual for Vegas we meet everybody who
wants to meet us after the show most
other Vegas shows you pay another couple
hundred bucks to meet the entertainers
we just meet everybody in the audience
and tell her talks to them and what I
love about how much you can trust the
audience is people who all we have a
conversation would tell there they come
over to me and say I love the way your
partner never speaks you know because
it's it's okay we can all do a
make-believe together we don't have to
lie to people
so tell there's very articulate as I
said
teacher right but it's chosen to see if
it's more interesting to be able to
distort reality without speaking and
anybody from the sports world that you
might have met and yes after well after
the show and also just I get back to the
green room just a while ago and Mike
Tyson was sleeping on our couch this was
a scene from hangover no it was actually
there sleeping on the couch okay bye
buddy I rat so Larry sloman wrote the
big tyson book where i'm sure and they
got to be friends and we got to know him
a little bit and he hangs out in your
green room back there cuz he was meeting
with ratso and doing some I guess I
should say Larry sloman but we all call
him right so he was doing some work with
them and cleaning up something and he
just ended up dozing off it was a little
late was toward the end of the show I go
back and there's Tyson so I just
thinking probably not good to wake him
up spur you know I mean you don't want a
case he's a little startled no reason
for me but III never never seen the
boxing match never seen anything even in
Vegas in all the years have you been in
Vegas
never and but I knew I knew Mike Tyson
and I'd also um Bill Russell has come to
our show a lot know can hand we we get
along wonderfully and people have told
me we get along so well because I don't
talk about basketball it's probably true
you know Penn he's only a little taller
than me so we can say stuff and because
it was his daughter is is a lawyer and
free speech stuff I know her from that
so I met her father from that so a lot
of sports guys come by and they're so
kind to me cuz when I say oops I I don't
know a lot about sports right uh they
often seem happy about that because they
probably want to just get immersed in
what's your into I really think that I'm
always a little embarrassed about that
but they're always so kind to me Penn
Jillette here on the Rich Eisen show
Penn & Teller foolís on the CW we'll
talk about that in a second I do want to
get into Vegas so was the first night
you played in Vegas
the first one I guess it was in the 90s
and it was pretty nutty because we were
considered to New York forgive me for
saying that but too intellectual for
Vegas
they thought it was foolish to book us
there and then our first night in Vegas
at the Bally's showroom the celebrity
room sold out sold out did very well
paint alleys that's was your first
casino that yes and also what's great
about this is we have the record for the
most tickets sold in the same room
Sinatra plate and the reason is because
Sinatra had friends and we didn't so we
sold every ticket that's amazing that's
how we beat Sanaa that's how you beat
sand I'm not having Fred's that's the
way you get over-the-top us or not so
you were headlining right from the
get-go or did you open for somebody
headlined right from the get-go in in in
in Vegas in Atlantic City
we at one point open for the temptations
but what was that like it was wonderful
wonderful and we also got to do a show
and this was such a thrill with BB King
who is in my opinion pathologically nice
he is the nicest human being I've ever
met in my life
and being backstage with BB King and
seeing Lucille and seeing all in his
guitar of course it's just the most
wonderful thing in the world that has to
be yeah so who else who else was in
Vegas when you were there headlining I
mean who obviously was Wayne Newton mr.
Wayne since we got there I don't think
you're allowed into Vegas without being
vetted by Wayne and yeah you know all
the we were we were there early enough
in the 90s right not to play the same
room when Dean Martin was still playing
there and you know Rodney Dangerfield I
remember coming backstage once and I
said Mike Mike Tyson in our green room
yeah I came back once and and Rodney
Dangerfield was in a robe in tellers
dressing room and I said to tell her I
didn't know you knew Rodney Dangerfield
the teller said I don't
he had come down to sue gamble in his in
his bathrobe and why not why not and he
had a a young woman with him who wanted
to meet Penn & Teller and he said no
problem and brought them back in to tell
his dressing robe of course all the
security guards it's Rodney Dangerfield
we were thrilled but it was an answer I
did not expect we tell us that I don't
know and then he was in the dressing
room and tell her and I visited with him
a little bit yeah
met the woman who wanted to meet us and
then we got changed we went home and
there was Rodney and tellers dressing
room but is it his bathrooms yeah he
would come down and gambol in his
bathrobe yeah cuz he's Rodney
Dangerfield in who's gonna try to push
our clothes on right
it was Terry right it was a terry cloth
robe I was it was one of the hotel room
hotel room you know and the high quality
robe there I'm sure I'm sure the the
Egyptian cotton thread count on his on
is probably probably amazing for sheets
and probably when he takes it home with
them they don't even mind of course not
doesn't show up on the bill show up on
the bill at all along with what videos
you watch don't show up unless you know
very well there are no titles apparently
but there's prices I never understood so
strange so strange and I wouldn't think
of and rubra cost $35 Penn Jillette Penn
& Teller right here on the Rich Eisen
show so the REO is that's gotta be cool
to go into a spot and there's your name
on the top you know my picture is 300
feet high that's in your writer right
yeah in your contract
and I love when people are interviewing
me and say what it feel like to see your
picture up there and I say well we had
meetings about it and I posed for the
picture okay so what's a surprise I love
this image that you'd be driving to work
all of a sudden well they put on my
picture how did that happen but I would
like to point out that my picture is
wicked
bigger than donny & marie together of
course for david copperfield or donny
murray and david copperfield together
I'm 300 feet tall and you can if you
like yes book a room that has a very
strategically placed window on my
picture in case you wanna you just want
to go there and see it I could tell you
the room number I take a look out of the
way you just wave from private party
service that service right there do you
have a favorite trick or you know you
kind of have you know teller and I have
this wonderful luxury we have five hours
of material that's that's current okay
and we're also writing new stuff but you
have to we change our show a lot and you
have to have the discipline to to always
think the [ __ ] you're doing it that
second is the best it's just not fair to
the audience to to be looking forward to
something else that being said the best
trick kua trick we've ever done I think
is the bullet catch which were rather
well-known for and my favorite thing is
a thing where an audience member turns
into teller because it doesn't really
have an antecedent I mean most every
trick in magic you look back and say
well so on so did a version of that and
right 1938 and so and so did this turn
this turn of the last century they were
someone in France that was doing it but
that trick is kind of sort of ours you
know we get someone up from the audience
and they turn into teller and it's
rather startling it was a hard trick so
for those who might not have seen it
they literally turn into well I was yes
but it's a it's a very big surprise I
get someone from the audience and there
is a switch that happens when the
audience is unaware of it and we really
got lucky you know a lot of times you
think of a trick and when you actually
get to putting it on stage it's it's
less good this is I think one of the
four or five tricks that ended up better
on stage that it was in our heads so I
get really excited we start doing that
and of course you know now you're able
to bring your brand
of magic and humor to the CW audience to
a larger audience than just obviously
people coming to see you now if they can
sit there and have you come to their
house sixth season of Penn & Teller fool
us what do you like about this what I
like about this is I do not like art
competition shows I don't like people
judging how well someone sings you know
unless you can show me a talent show on
TV where Bob Dylan son Ron Tiny Tim win
nice choices I'm skeptical yes but our
show what we are competing on if I want
to use that is very very constrained
it's just did you fool us not is your
trick good not did the audience love you
not that you fool anyone else but just
did you happen to fool us and it makes
it a very very polite gentle persons
game and it comes from what really
happened you know the the capital of
magic in the world is Las Vegas
and most magicians end up visiting there
and then they end up backstage at our
show very often and we've noticed that
when they're in the green room backstage
when Tyson isn't there wouldn't want to
wake them up right they'll often say hey
did you see this and they'll pull out a
trick and do it for us and then there's
this wonderful moment afterwards where
everybody in the room just knows whether
we know that trick or not you know
litora teller says oh yeah it's a nice
version of that or whether teller goes
what whoa hmm and that moment is kind of
nice and sweet and pleasant and we
decided to move that on to TV it also
teaches people that the camera people
are not on the side of the magician I
mean there's no camera tricks they're
sitting there they do it once we follow
all the rules we never know who's coming
on and what trick they're gonna do and
we get just one time through the trick
do we happen to know how that trick is
done and when we first putting it
together the producers are going what
are they write down how much done and
then you write it down and if someone
compares I don't know it'll all be done
with eye contact we all all know right
and everybody's very polite and nice
very sweet and the people who have been
most successful in their careers
afterwards are often the people that
didn't fool us well the people who do
fool you get to be in your ass has that
happened in hell yeah what does that
happen in the six years I know how much
sports guys love status yes
so about 12 percent 12 percent of the
people who are on foolís okay you know
there there are really good magicians
and I would say 90% of them are
righteous fools and then 10% are we were
looking away at the wrong time or they
did it one way we knew another or
something like that that it gets a
little bit iffy but boy you know you get
into magic not because you like to fool
people but because you love being fooled
and then you keep chasing that first
high because the more you know the less
you're fooled and we're in this
wonderful position where having been in
magic for our entire adult lives we
still have people come on fool us
although I will tell you we are scouring
the world now the producer said well
next year next season don't expect
anyone to speak English we've gone
through a lot of the a lot of the
barricade blocks I've enjoyed again you
and teller together for for for a long
time appreciative of you coming on the
show right anytime thank you up and tell
our fool us erring Mondays at 8:00
Eastern 7:00 central on the CW could
stream it next day free only on the CW
app Penn Jillette here in the Rich Eisen
show thanks man thanks for coming on
really appreciate that for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app